en toute simplicité presque incognito
michel crouzet fait quelques courses
dans le centre ville de sens depuis son
élection
hier elle est pourtant député de l'yonne
elles mesurent l'importance d'un tel
mandat
mais veut rester accessible à tous des
dieux surtout c'est de pas changé assez
de rester toujours toujours soi même et
puis voilà c'est vrai qu'on a maintenant
des fois on a un respect un grade à voir
mais une prestance peut-être à voir mais
elle n'empêche que pour les gens
seraient toujours je serai toujours que
je suis dans les rues les habitants
l'interpellent pour la féliciter la
salue d'un bonjour madame le député il y
encore trois mois
le des lecteurs connaissent et la
conseillère départementale alors
centriste et udi mais une majorité a
voté pour la candidate en marche chez
vous et vous la connaissez depuis
combien de temps en temps quelques élus
très peu de temps j'ai assisté à
quelques réunions et j'ai été rapidement
séduit d'études façon qu'on connaît ce
qu'on connaisse pas il faut faire
confiance
ya tout de même un arrière des arrières
en marche n'a pas sélectionner n'importe
qui mariée mère de trois enfants michel
crouzet est aussi chef d'entreprise
ici à sens mais va devoir laisser son
mari gérer seuls leur société elle veut
se consacrer pleinement à son mandat de
député mais aussi sur une chose elles ne
changera pas je vais garder mes
convictions je vais garder mon optimisme
je suis quelqu'un de très optimiste qui
en a beaucoup et qui a envie de faire
et à partir de là je pense que ça sera
que profitable pour la circonscription
ce qui va changer pour michel crouzet le
quotidien et des kilomètres parcourus
la députée en marche sera dès mercredi à
paris à l'assemblée nationale